back onto the
hasso's so we've done the passageuch
the next one is hasagaishi ski
so they can all be done with the same
footwork and
same understanding
okay so as i'm saying in the first
essay use your feelings sort of feel
your joke
feel the movement even if you feel like
you're going
up and then you're going to come down
this is how i feel and and watching some
of cytosense's earlier
films when he was sort of i don't know
perhaps in his 50s or younger even
black and white ones you'll see him more
expressional
as he got older he was more refined but
he didn't see these expressions
exaggerated but um we you know
we must uh take from the past
the future that uh was as he got older
and we mustn't just do what he done when
he got older because
we won't experience the joy of that
house
this hand must not
stop here must pass
past your head
must not stop here
i like the feeling of going up
sliding it down keeping it within my
body frame not outside my body frame
when you get to the end it's like a
hammer punch now
and you're thrusting if you don't have
an a target that should paint it on the
wall or
a target somewhere aim for your own
heart area
center of your chest that's where you're
skiing too
feet together this time
from this position from this position
you can just let it go down
and change hands
change hands
back to the hasso as it gathers in the
front foot turns the same as before
and finish in the come my position
uh i'm still debating about the
slight lean back but it feels quite nice
i normally say don't go back if you're
going to go forward
but you can play around with this one
don't let the tip drop too much
well you got to bring it now up to ski
hey so the leaning back i like because
it
it alters the pinpoint of the joe
okay so i i as i said
on the previous film
the body can have more swaying movement
more characteristics
of you blending where the joe has to go
rather than do it too robotic
so
okay
so that that one was with the three
different footwork
so that's the guy she ski
when the thrust is low
so that's the hasakashi ski with the
different footwork the different hasso's
i hope this helps you uh find
if you had a nice feeling already that's
great
i hope there's something in there that
can help you improve your father
thank you for your time